how's it going everybody so by now we
know that the quantum realm is going to
play a pretty significant part in
Avengers 4 before ant-man and the wasp
came out Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige said that it connects directly to
Avengers 4 and then in the post-credits
scene we heard the words time vortex
everybody pretty much assumes that time
travel is going to play a significant
role in Avengers 4 as well and as soon
as we heard the word time vortex that's
when everybody put it together and said
okay the quantum realm is going to be
how the Avengers go back through time
but as it turns out we could actually be
downplaying the role of the quantum
realm quite a bit I'm still doing my
giveaway giving away copies of Infinity
Ward Deadpool 2 and ant-man and the wasp
on blu-ray as well as some special
edition posters if you would like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
you may have heard some actors come out
and talk about just how important the
quantum realm is most notably was
Michael Douglas he came out and said
that the quantum realm is the key then
he said that it's not just the key in
Avengers 4 but in the next chapter of
all Marvel films and now in a recent
interview Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige has spoken up again about the
importance of the quantum realm he said
that at the end of ant-man we follow
Scott Lang into the quantum realm for
the first time we were beginning to peel
back the onion that would later be
completely peeled back and Doctor
Strange as we go into the multiverse so
that was our little test into that but
now the quantum realm is a whole other
territory that we can play with to tell
our stories this quantum realm is much
larger than we ever imagined and there
are all sorts of adventures to be had at
that level which perhaps we will explore
in another film so a few things that he
said sort of stick out and the first one
is multiverse keep in mind
nobody from Marvel or Disney has
confirmed anything about time travel and
Avengers 4 now there most likely will be
time travel but let's not forget about
the Avengers going into alternate
realities this happens in the comics and
a very early plot leaked and people who
have said too seen raw footage of the
movie will say that the Avengers will go
into different realities to collect
finiti stones and bring them back into
their reality now in the comics the
Infinity stones only work in the reality
in which they were made but it's the MCU
they can do whatever they want an
alternate reality certainly open up the
MCU a lot which is what Kevin Feige
could be talking about when he says that
it's much larger than he ever imagined
and that's using the quantum realm as
sort of a portal into other realities
but the quantum realm itself is huge and
when the Avengers explore it they could
make some pretty big discoveries
recently people at Marvel told us to
pause ant-man and the wasp at a
particular moment and we did and we
discovered a city inside of the quantum
realm due to a recent toy leak we
learned that the Avengers are going to
be facing a greater threat a lot of
people believe that this means there's
going to be another villain besides
Thanos in Avengers 4 perhaps this is
where that second villain is and when
the Avengers go inside the quantum realm
they get the villains attention we
recently learned that the majority of
the remaining Avengers will be going
inside of the quantum realm perhaps
they're going to have to fight another
villain inside the quantum realm whether
they do or not what Kevin Feige is
saying is that the quantum realm is
going to last a lot longer than just
Avengers 4 there's clearly people inside
of the quantum realm probably both
heroes and villains ones that will most
likely run into after the events of
Avengers 4 which is what Kevin Feige is
saying what he's saying is that the
quantum realm is going to have a big
surprise for us in Avengers 4 but it's
going to continue on past Avengers 4 and
interface 4 of the MCU and future movies
so what or who do you think is inside of
the quantum realm and who do you think
they'll introduce after Avengers 4 in
phase 4 of the MCU let me know what you
all think in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]